now
um you had said something to me last
week you said you're around
young money enough to to see everyone
get kicked out at least once
[Laughter]
oh [ __ ] i said that to you i did i did
i did so explain to me the
times in which both nikki and drake were
kicked out of young money because that
seems like an
uh preposterous thing you want to hear
you want to hear the story about how
nikki and drake
were once kicked out it was probably
only lasted about a day or two right
but what do you want to hear when i got
kicked out
all of it but which which one do you
want to hear first whatever you feel
inclined to i'll give you the nikki and
drake [ __ ] first because they're bigger
names and
that'll probably be more entertaining
for y'all i remember
or i started with nikki nikki if you
remember at one time she was managed by
deb
uh waka moms yep yeah and deb had her
work and had her out there with gucci
and
you know i think dad was managing french
at that time so she used to do like some
[ __ ] like
gucci a b-book but french and nikki
get a bag too and they come together so
it got to a point when we started going
out because we used to
record a lot in atlanta miami and [ __ ]
like that but now when
carter three come out wayne on the road
and
he used to tell us [ __ ] like he used to
tell me a lot
this is what made me start coming he was
like yo i don't think it's fair to the
other artist that you get to go home
and then fly back when you want to come
back out like they don't go home
they just they on the road with me but i
had never been a part of nothing like
that to understand an
artist like him that lives on the road
like lives on a tour bus you know what
i'm saying i was more like i when y'all
come to new york or you want me to come
back out let me know
his thing was mills i [ __ ] with you you
need to be here
whenever what you're there for what
you're doing there right young money
ain't in new york
we on the road why are you there you
young money right and then it hit me
like
all right i gotta be here more so nikki
at that time she was booked so she got
her
own she's building like her own nikki
lewinsky
you know i'm saying she building her own
little thing beam me up scotty tape
in them clubs like she was getting them
getting bags while we ride on the bus
with wayne
and we you know he bringing us out she's
doing that too but
she might have a bag to get in south
carolina or here
and i think he started to feel like you
know he never wanted nobody to feel like
they was better than another artist like
i don't want nikki to feel like she
better than
chanel or guns just because she booked
but i don't want mills to feel like he
bigger than twists or chucky
just because he'd been on tv with diddy
before and he did battles and he had
deals like
we all at the same level y'all all the
same level feel right now like let's
look don't look down on nobody
because i ain't looking down on you now
if you're gonna look down on a little
chucky a little twist or you're gonna
look down on guns
i gotta look down on you now mills i
have to
you know what i'm saying like so once we
got that [ __ ] in our mind
wayne was looking at it i think like
nikki doing her own thing
i think wayne was looking at it on some
[ __ ] like
oh she trying to be over here and over
here
and kind of see which one popped first
you got to remember it wasn't no
every girl in the world yet it wasn't no
we was just wayne's
crew you know what i'm saying but gucci
was still gucci like french wasn't
big big big french montana yet but he
coke boys and he so he don't know if
like nicki was
like you [ __ ] know you over here like
you [ __ ] with us are you [ __ ] with
them you [ __ ]
and i think he just had one of them days
where he was like yo she ain't younger
money no more like
and then she started just working she'll
be at video shoots here and there change
hair color
start wearing tight dresses and did he
tell that to her i don't know if he i
don't i don't want to say he told it to
her he probably told mac
or toltez to call or whatever she never
said nothing she
he never said nothing and then
him being a businessman and just
understanding where he trying to take
young money
i think he told mack ortez like yo we
put in too much work
to just let her go like tell her i said
you know what i'm saying and then she
was back on the road with us but she was
still doing her own thing
but she was back in a row but i could
understand how he could feel like that
because it's like yo
is you over here or is you over there is
you not like what are you doing right
now you know what i'm saying so they
came to their agreement and after that
everything was cool you know what i'm
saying but i think it was a
misunderstanding it wasn't like it was a
miscommunication
somewhere same thing with the drake [ __ ]
i think wayne and drake thing at that
time was more so wayne and tez
you know what i'm saying like wayne
trusting ted's with [ __ ]
and then finding out like some [ __ ]
might not be what it is
and like but now drake is in the middle
of it
because it's like you know it's that
business that paperwork [ __ ] and like
all of that type of [ __ ]
i think that was an issue you know what
i'm saying i was in the studio with
drake in new york
and cool
chilling everything cool smoking
recording and he went up
we went in the hallway came back and i
was like
he's like yeah man he's like tune just
tell me i'm not young money no more
same thing you just did i was like like
where the [ __ ] that come from like
because this is at a time where like
every girl is out
like we you know we charting like
drake's doing like uh say something
and digital girl like he's doing like
features now for mary jay
and drake i mean not drake mary j jamie
foxx
yeah he's doing like [ __ ] outside of the
box and i think it was that same thing
again
it was like that yo what y'all like
cause there's so much [ __ ] going on but
wayne don't know
you know what i'm saying he don't know
what the [ __ ] is going on with his
artists and i think that was the thing
with drake it wasn't it wasn't really
nothing with drake because even drake
told him he was like
he said it really don't have nothing to
do with you
and me just knowing wayne i know he was
having one of them days where it's like
[ __ ] is everybody keeping me in the dark
with [ __ ] if these is this is my [ __ ]
you know what i'm saying and
just once again miscommunication miss
seeing the same thing with [ __ ] what
little twist
i mean we don't i mean little twist
wasn't in the bedrock video if you
noticed little chucky was
all through the bedrock video but he
wasn't on the song
was it is it because wayne was in
[ __ ] matter because got him trouble
in school or some [ __ ] like that
oh wow or tutoring or something
happening with his mom's like
so wayne wouldn't let him be in the
video he just let little chucky be all
through he let little chucky be the
extra in
everybody's verse that's so funny